Nicole is somebody who knows Jamal so
well how impressive as what he's done
this year been from what he's come back
from injury-wise and is it cool to see
him finally get in the national
attention for as good as he has been
when he's been healthy for you guys
I mean I think he deserves especially
because he he added a lot he had 30
points on the great percentage you know
that thing that's that's really hard to
do especially on that that high number
of points but not just not just points I
think his energy all the same even from
the first round his energy he's he was
he has been our best player since since
uh since round one and he's really
stepping up and
um
in that direction like being in even if
he doesn't make shots doesn't that his
energy is always good and uh I think
that's that's the the best
um
feeling for the guys around him you know
you know yes we know he can make sure
that he can go for 50 but even when
things doesn't go his way he doesn't
fall down he's still into it he's still
playing he's still fighting and I think
that's the best the best uh the best uh
thing about him right now and
I mean to be honest you cannot control
what people are going to talk about you
or not talk about you so I'm not even
going to comment of no no is he is he
does he deserve or not I think he
deserved but
who am I
Nicola Jamal yesterday was in here
talking about kind of his rookie year in
the early stages playing alongside you
when you guys are both coming off the
bench do you remember kind of the early
stages of playing with him and do you
remember any early signs of thinking
that playing alongside him was special
and that you guys had a really good
chemistry
my first my first couple has ever had a
really good chemistry with Gary Harris
if you guys remember we had that was a
really good a nice two-game uh two-man
game that we have and then kind of
slowly build up to Jamal
um but uh he he always had that fight in
inside him he always said there's
something that kind of he was uh
I don't want to say chasing something
where he was here was to be be
be better be more be he always wanted to
be something you know bigger that he was
in that moment and I think
if I remember him if I'm one thing that
I remember him when I'm in my rookie
year it was that like his he was always
hungry for more